right here hopefully this is not a dick
pic and things get weird you know what I
need from you mom I think I need more
stories from you about my
entrepreneurship nobody knows that more
than you
it's this heartening to know it can
never really go there you know what I
mean
it's DNA
born on or born willing to look at half
festival have glass empty I mean that's
just real you know what I mean that's
why I'm so blind to I don't think I'm
special I think I got lucky and this
will for a week or two while I figure it
out are 30 to 90 second clips from that
episode with a link to the YouTube like
the clip is native and then the copy is
a length of YouTube got it correct you
know truth is I didn't read books I
didn't look up to entrepreneurs growing
up it's such a different era growing up
in the 80s and early 90s businessmen and
women weren't heralded or they
definitely weren't pop-culture enough
for 14 or 17 or 22 year old to know what
the hell was going on we need to spend
30 to 60 days together before I do that
house a house what's up snapchat it's me
Gary but you know that fire questions
away I'm gonna try to answer a bunch
later today I've got a moment so fire
them Wow
nice okay no coughing just making a call
Oh fine
I don't know the truth is I don't know
I'm meeting with her and within 30 days
to have like a real kind of business
chat so hey hey brother go let's see
yeah good seeing you there you go
we'll enjoy the other day hello aren't
you Mark Gary Vaynerchuk nice to meet
how are you well thank you so much
he was a good meeting yeah we had a lot
of fun the reason I spent time at the
boot and auction is I was a major
baseball card collectible kid and I used
to come to Parsippany baseball card show
on Tuesday nights at the Holiday Inn for
years so still going on I'm not sure
what it did you yeah
still do they're just purchase what
year's mid 60's to mid seventies really
in good shape
hey K KB how are you so good day a
little bit of snapchat engagement we all
do that right now
actually it's 2-1 right now so that's
good I'm just starting to get into book
primetime
that's kind of cool right d-roc
hopefully this is not a dick pic and
things get weird let's go I'll of it
darling I run I grew a huge wine retail
business a store and a.com
from three to sixty million dollars in
sales as my first chapter that was one
tell a bell and now I run a 600 person
digital agency I look good today by the
way I don't if you noticed 600 person
digital agency think of it as Mad Men
2016 jela villain
you don't think I look like a black
black always look good yeah I feel like
I look really good today
Kyle protec guy let's see you get good
you good or want to go here it's
probably been better right
look I understand light now do you rock
what's the most unconditional I can use
to grow my well growing get me to repair
business in such a crowded marketplace
there's tons a computer repair companies
out there and it seems Harbinger great
question
Kyle Google AdWords it will just work
people are trying to find that stuff
plus you have to put out content I see
your face you can do it put out little
40-second tips on how to repair okay I'm
about to give really good advice that I
want all of you to pay attention to my
[ __ ] keep my car
see the thing that people don't realize
is you want to teach people how to fix
things without paying you for it because
that builds up leverage you give up a
sale in the beginning but you get all
the sales in the end I'm going to send
Gary the one snapchat video every single
day so he agrees to do an interview for
supporting our young leaders podcast
Kevin I like the hustle so it sounds
like what you're saying is you're going
to make a snapchat video to try to
convince me to do a podcast every day
until I do it now it's going to be the
interesting part of this equation what's
going to be interesting is to see how
much intestinal fortitude you have how
much patience you have young man how bad
do you want it I think media content
websites for distribution is a real
complement to what vaynermedia does what
up yo yo yo hey yo yo yo yo yo yo Kuwait
in the house Austin here headed to a
meeting
boy loving you always a big fan of
Jacksonville Seattle Seattle Seattle
debating a Seattle book tour
I just tweeted up check it out just
tweeted that I've got three dates
7th 9th and 10th of March available to
go anywhere in the US for bulk book buys
looking forward to that but the big
announcement
why jumped on periscope is the super 8
super the number 8 at vaynermedia comm
the big event on February 23rd 10 a.m.
to 6 p.m.
how many of you are familiar with what
I'm doing on super 8 Larchmont I love
how many people familiar with what's
going on on February 23rd say yes and no
say yes and no I want all 600 of you
responded yes and no yes and no a lot of
knows good because I haven't really been
promoting yet a lot of knows move lots
of knows that's good that excites me
Dirac d-roc doing daily be 13 a lot of
knows all these knows alright go to
garyvaynerchuk.com go to my blog it's
just been posted super 8 March to March
February 23rd from 10 a.m. to 6 p.m. I'm
going to go live streaming periscope
meerkat Facebook live for 8 hours right
10:06 to buy 8 copies and then email
them to super 8 at vaynermedia comm if
you I will draw a receipt and one of you
will get the thousand book deal which is
coming to New York on my dime I will fly
you to New York or Drive you or you will
walk over to vaynermedia and we will
spend one hour together doing whatever
you want focusing on building out your
business and interview shooting the [ __ ]
about technology one hour for me to
consult or bring you the most possible
value ever and I think it's going to be
unbelievable
to have some ideas unlike business
development aspects mainly less so about
though I'll take it hi guys no Sherri's
no hazelnuts dressing on the side edge
hi I much rather do a little bit of
half-and-half instead of skim I'm doing
neither now I'm doing I'm all I'm an
oilskin now I love it
which sucks I love half-and-half even
even in my prime that's six months yeah
I only did skin like 23% time I love
half and I don't like I don't even like
coffee with skin I like it with
half-and-half and lots of half-and-half
like tons of having AB yeah that's not
good I know I'm super [ __ ] [ __ ] no no
I'm going little skin I love it
I'm in such a mindset right now that I
want to just go black should we do black
coffee yeah
no I still
it's coming bang let's go together then
how are you very good good it's full o
the hitchhiking yes
oh you're here how are you man Congrats
to meet you
congrats for making me Jay what's him at
10 you weren't here so I just came back
kind of hung out
it's not to be a like see people real
like it's real yeah it's funny kink show
can you give me two seconds to get
settled
where's the mail it was just here maybe
right well sup you rock I did it I made
it I made it again it's been a while I
missed you all
what else any anything no let's go you
don't know keeping your phone with me
cuz it needs to get to a hundred because
you're gone okay let him know uh Jed Jed
it may sound I don't meet you
real pleasure so yeah we're here yeah no
Mike can you help me I'm bad at this
yeah yeah thummell miked like a double
rainbow
since this is a rarity you like that one
we'll have a waiter we have answer yeah
you're gonna be in the blog you good
it's very hard to calculate the ROI when
you're not in control of how the whole
thing gets sold or if you're doing other
activities
let me explain if you're running
snapchat as sour patch kids or a car
company or a tennis ball company if
you're also doing radio and television
and your product is being sold at
7-eleven and Walmart you just really
don't know most these companies don't
shut off everything and just do snapchat
and then see what happens
oh we have 28 weeks of consistent sales
now it's gone down 8% snapchat didn't
work or now we going up 15% it worked
yeah what what am i doing next um AJ is
you for 30 seconds yep what do you think
about us moving to 12 for a little while
me you yeah and I'm moving what our
infrastructure sure play with that yeah
in your head I want to do that I
personally want to do as one you let me
start over
let me get my actual KPI I want to be on
12 with you I watched the latest
dailyvee okay you talked about a fact
you don't like dogs yes which I'm fine
with
yes I'm gonna say camp that was me
hyperbolized on how much I love people
I'm not confused that dogs are nice and
that oxygen matters and mother nature's
a good thing like I'm not a I'm not a
I'm not lost to those things of course
not I'm I was laughing at the comments
last night like you know dude without
mother nature to be no oxygen you'd be
dead dude if there was no trees you
couldn't print paper and you wouldn't be
able to sell ask everyone like guys I'm
joking
yet some at the main point is I love
humans I'm in the same camp I just I
just I was funny because when I heard
that first of all yeah
and I always feel like such a jerk yeah
well I tried to do it for people like us
I appreciate that yeah we need our own
care we need our community Gary how are
you great pleasure to meet you nice to
meet you man Oh an operation here very
impressive thank you brother
instead of millions I'm focused now on
hundreds of millions or billions sure
I've always felt that I've had a destiny
to do something greater good not
necessary to be famous I get it but to
do something more substantial and and
then so give so given that I have to do
a public speech what's the main question
what should you do next I think the main
I think really I came to try to just get
some energy from you got it I don't hear
here's the real energy I think you need
to put out cut if you want to do
hundreds of millions and you want to
build you and you're willing to be out
there which is reject all the clear
indications you are you have to put out
content you've got to put out content
every day so so my question to that is
as I've studied and as I'm sure you've
seen a lot of the content it's the same
content but done in a different way or a
different spin yeah stuff but done
differently of course so is that yeah I
did take look I'll give you a better
piece of advice than that I would do you
yeah like I even said the other day in
dailyvee I don't want to be a
motivational speaker I'm motivating that
I'm high energy yes but I continue at
all costs to not consume any of it
because then it's not me
correct what I am is motivational but
I'm building for 600 [ __ ] people
working here I'm like [ __ ] up Madison
Avenue because I'm revolutionising the
advertising world in agency form the way
I did for liquor stores
I didn't read those guys to build wine
library I did me now it sounds like
you've consumed some of that which is
fine my biggest piece of advice is to
unwind that and be you but I think you
just have to go honest as [ __ ] and I
will tell you the number one thing that
scares the [ __ ] out of me nice watches
and Ferraris here's what I mean do not
sell these people
shall be real it's got to be valuable
because you'll make money but your
grandkids are gonna think you were dick
right understood you build an actual
[ __ ] business
you're not a [ __ ] self-help coach
that only sells info products it comes
down to very simple things which is do
not get caught up in taking a [ __ ]
pretty picture like on a vacation on a
[ __ ] boat on Instagram and selling
these people [ __ ] yeah everybody's
doing that it's everywhere you go you
built a business that's what you pound
on okay and if you happen to be
motivating and charismatic all the
better all the [ __ ] better yeah but
there's plenty of people that none of
these people have never heard of yeah
making Bank and they're not charismatic
and they're not clever and are not cute
or interesting they're just [ __ ]
making hundreds of billions of dollars
running businesses but though further
you're willing to go down the truth
barrel the more you're gonna win I think
all I can tell you is if you get
anything out of me is all the hyperbole
in the [ __ ] and drama and excitement
and energy and accolades that I have the
thing I feel best about and you know my
dad took better than you know me is
there's truth behind it I love that
because I know a lot of people that
there are isn't yeah and don't be one of
those people it's too easy you've made a
new blade that's nice some answer let me
know man like those are those are
hundreds of thousands and millions for
the couple people that are the best at
being [ __ ] you've already made that
look the [ __ ] are you gonna play in
hundreds of thousands and millions you
want something real watch something
[ __ ] real play for tens and hundreds
that only comes in real [ __ ] don't sell
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's not true
there's no [ __ ] secret the secret
isn't real like I hope that's not real
it's [ __ ] work right like you know
how you build a business in 20 years you
[ __ ] work your face off like you woke
up at 6 I went to the job and it snowed
but you got to show up because if that
person said you were a dick then this
organization wasn't gonna use you talk
about accountability talk about when
there's only three or four major
builders in New Jersey that you can't
[ __ ] up ever because once your
reputation [ __ ] you're out
there's a million people that want to
[ __ ] insulate yeah got it
you're the man man I don't initiate it
take care of it much stay well I wish
you out very much my pleasure
how long is it gonna be because I want
it when I make when I sell it
yep or 213 or you know what I mean
don't even let it be close be like oh
seven or thirteen something like that
thank you my friend good tune you tune
in tell me all about yourself yes that I
know I I saw on some social media stuff
it seemed like you did some TV
interviews I did a lot of TV recently
ran into a guy from from Germany the
student and he began a nearly 3,000 mile
long American adventure without a dime
in his pocket he's depending entirely on
the kindness of others his goal is to
make it to New York City and in New York
City I want to get on the live show on
the on the web show of Gary Vaynerchuk
on the askgaryvee show that is a mango
this is everything that you're taking
right that's all I'm taking and this is
basically my ticket to New York so what
you got to talk about now experience
yeah it's amazing right yes you should
write a book actually I think about
tell me more about yourself you got
siblings sisters very nice for the
business and Johnny wedding gonna jump I
think this girlfriend right now
can for you you actually introduced me
to you and I thought you are weird I am
weird and I showed you of my house
instead of my show to yesterday yes it
is like a constant stuff I get it's just
too much energy
oh I totally get it I know that
sometimes oh yeah I mean I'm not a I'm
not confused at that like that the
energy gets to people listen any time
you do a business that goes from zero to
something it's amazingly well yeah and
I've been working every day for 20 years
you know what I mean
so what yeah I mean I don't I don't I
don't ever say I never say to somebody
you know the first year I met Facebook
they were losing money they did
amazingly well so you know yeah I think
I think it's incredible good for you oh
look at Dennis
do you know dennis is gonna be here
Dennis look at this you get to be a
dealer you to thank ya again it's great
to see it really good yeah yeah good
stuff here I'll catch up with you all
right ma'am talking come by and that's
why we do it
Dennis dog one of your first business to
get it going right yes
is that right it was like [ __ ] Mike
selling trees and [ __ ] yes and to get
the
yes if it sometimes yes I'm so [ __ ]
that's a love it I love it it's the
hustlers mentality it's the same thing
you got to tell the person you stayed
with that couldn't stand me that I want
to be his friend yeah all right I have
to McCall
give me excuse me for one second there's
a dude that hitchhiked across the
country oh really yeah I know who you
all right god it feel is it gonna snow
in Boston tomorrow tomorrow yes it is
gonna feel like it actually yes of
course Kevin right look like it's
terrible okay well you know who are
looking like this
Bobby this is Gary by this is my son
Mateo hey McHale how are you good my god
it's got the scale storm y'all so I'm
young oh no no buzzer [ __ ] so you can
take
what up the euro ha my man okay I can do
this
go ahead this is Gary Vaynerchuk ask the
askgaryvee dailyvee the dailyvee have
you ever watched the daily bean
I've watched it daily beyond one snap
I'm in there with you all right Jack
threads in the cut right here yes kid is
rapping
how are you brother gonna feel ready
going on it's gonna suck yes Gary
Vaynerchuk was the best video in my
entire talk about the effort that was
put into that video nailed it
as a matter of fact if you know what the
rock show a clip of Barry Boehner suck
Gary's alter egos bury their son
honestly everybody is so much hustle
these days they want to start the next
billion dollar app uber Airbnb Facebook
it's crazy it's pathetic I'm here to
tell you it's impossible to be
successful if you don't like what you're
doing continue doing it stop trying to
own [ __ ] please stop guys this is Ryan
alone
say hi Lana I love your body my name is
Ryan Aloha is way out here [ __ ] yes this
man is gonna huge on snapchat literally
never seen this before
hello your story I'm a duty ball look at
this [ __ ] movie
Wow I've never seen it so rare I'm a
serious kick this is my friend Ryan and
he reminds me so much of me like he's a
real businessman
lingzi entertaining that's why this is
my man Derek my new friend I'm about to
convince them to get on snapchat right I
just tweeted about super 8
meeting meeting
meeting [ __ ] for adventures how
we're meeting topic working we're
working